our goal is to ensure that the solution of
water problems becomes an integral
part of the
world environmental strategy
we have gathered at a time when the world is
experiencing an unprecedented global
crisis
crisis of its development models the
water crisis is an integral part of the general
crisis and above all the crisis of world
politics  sources of water
causes international conflicts
eighty percent and fat
infectious diseases are
caused by the use of
poor quality water in developing
countries about 95 percent of all
surface waters are polluted in the
european union region water-related diseases
die every day 37 children
unfortunately policy is
belatedly responding to
this truly emergency
if  this will continue tomorrow it
will be too late for the
current situation, including
Europe,
we must pay tribute to Europe, which has
faced difficult conditions in the past ten  It
should be the idea that
water, as the most important human
resource, is a common property and that
access to it should be
allowed as a fundamental human right,
I hope that our discussions will
contribute to those  the searches that are now underway
and from which I will say without involving y and the
future of mankind depends on the model for
attention
[applause]
[music]